Apple Watch series 9 versus Ultra 2 here
are 25 differences number one the
packaging is really premium on the ultra
it looks very adventurous and has a nice
presentation number two the Chargers are
different you get a standard plastic
charging cable with the standard Apple
watch and if you get the stainless it's
upgraded to a metal version but the
Ultras come with a braided cable which
you cannot buy separately and number
three is the design the regular Apple
watches look Sleek they look nice and
they fit with all sorts of different
clothing whereas the Ultras well they
look very sporty especially with the
included watch band so I upgraded mine
and it makes it fit a lot better with
nicer more formal attire but you still
have the orange button on the side
number four are the weights the ultra is
so much heavier than standard Apple
watches and you absolutely notice that
on your hand it takes a while to get
used to it and number five adds on to
that with thickness the ultra is way
thicker almost double when you look at
them side by side and to me that is not
a good thing it takes a while to get
used to and if you're going to be using
the sleep tracking it is way less
comfortable number six is the
waterproofing you have 50 meters
compared to a hundred on the ultra now I
think for most people that's not going
to make a difference but that just goes
into the water features which is number
seven the ultra comes with depth sensors
water temperature sensing specific
things for diving you guys could see how
it's designed for adventure and if
you're going to be in the ocean which I
have used this in the ocean you don't
have to worry about anything and you're
gonna have extra features if you do
those kinds of things now number 8 also
has to do with adventuring and that is
the Dual frequency GPS which is more
accurate than the standard one so it
could be quicker at acquiring a signal
and have more accuracy now with that for
number nine we have the exclusive
wayfinder face with the instant compass
that updates that is really nice if you
need to track where you're gonna go now
personally I've only used it a couple
times even though I do like hiking but
that is a nice feature and same thing
with number 10 which is the night mode
that you can get for low light
visibility conditions and it also looks
pretty cool where you don't get that
with the regular Apple watch now 11 if
you get lost you have an 86 decibel
siren that can be heard up to 600 feet
away on the ultra this thing gets loud
now that's not only for hiking and being
in the wilderness if you just want to be
safe or you're walking around at night
in the city that is that something
that's nice to get attention and to
scare people off if you need to number
12 are the differences in speakers the
ultra is a lot louder than the regular
Apple watch and that's not only because
of thicker larger size but actually has
two speakers built in instead of one go
ahead and take a listen to this sound
comparison
[Music]
number 13 are the microphone differences
we have three microphones instead of one
now in environments like this it's not a
huge difference but if you're in louder
environments or you're Outdoors where
there's wind noise the ultra will be
able to pick up your voice better for
calls number 14 gets into durability and
this one is huge now if you get the
series 9 that is the regular price
aluminum model that will scratch very
easily both my wife's and my son's
aluminum ones scratched up very easily
now the stainless one is more durable
but it still shows micro scratches and
it's not as durable as the ultra the
first gen Apple watch Ultra I had it for
about a year and it still looks like new
16th on the list is the display
materials the aluminum regular Apple
watches come with ion X glass which is
hardened compared to sapphire crystal
now the Ultra comes with that sapphire
crystal and the stainless steel models
of the regular Apple watch do as well
but Jerry Eric everything tested them
and it looks like the Ultras actually
come with slightly harder more pure
Sapphire that is more durable with that
the ultra has that flat design which
protects the screen so because of that
my ultra still looks like new even
though I've hit it against things quite
often now with that said it can also
damage things like it can literally take
off chunks of my fingernail because it's
a very sharp edge so if you bump into it
you might be damaging other surfaces 17
are the screen sizes we have 49
millimeters on the ultra compared to 41
and 45. now the large screen is really
nice you have some more unique watch
faces that can fit more complications
and in general it is so nice to look at
everything and get more screen real
estate on there and for the next one if
you are going to be typing which is way
better than trying to do the little
drawings on on them well it is much
easier on this large flat display the
next one is display brightness this is
huge we have 2 000 nits compared to 1000
and this is really nice for outdoor use
in the sun you never have to squint or
try to look the ultra is so bright and
you also get a better brighter
flashlight feature and next we have the
action button built in where you can
customize what it will do you can start
workouts you could do the siren you
could do the flashlight and that's
something you don't get with the regular
one and that can be convenient and for
the next one you also have that Crown
guard on the side with the regular Apple
watches this Crown is sticking out so if
you're out and about you're bending your
wrist you can constantly activate Siri
where with the ultra it helps you not
activate it on accident and for the next
one something that's not advertised is
the stronger haptic motors with the
Ultras when you're scrolling you feel it
much better it's more responsive it's
just a nice little extra touch and then
for the next one the biggest reason for
me to go with the ultra is the better
battery life now we have larger battery
sizes almost double but in the real
world even though the actual rating is
double on the ultra I've actually got
closer to three times the capacity
because a lot of things that run in the
background like running the OS and
notifications they take the same amount
of power on both but for the ultra it
takes much less of the overall capacity
now apple is putting the same new chip
in both which is going to help out with
battery life on the series 9 but it
still won't be as good and the next one
is the colors the ultra has titanium and
with the ultra two it looks like we're
gonna get dark titanium whereas the
regular Apple watch has a lot more color
options that pop a bit more and then the
last one that I really want to cover are
the prices you're looking at an Apple
Watch that is basically twice the price
if you're looking for the aluminum one
now of course if you're gonna add on a
larger size and then if you're gonna get
a cellular your prices get much closer
and then if you get a stainless steel
model well the price tag is very close
it's pretty much a moot point there but
you get so much more features packed
into the ultra too than the series nine
now there's a chance that Apple might be
making a smaller size Ultra which would
make it a little bit lower price and I
really hope they do that because it's
going to help them sell and it's going
to help with the size and weight and
with the comfort and then a lot more
people will be able to get it instead of
this huge heavy uh full-size 49
millimeter Apple watch Ultra let me know
if those extra features are worth it to
you and which one you will be buying
click that Circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those videos right over
there
foreign